so jetzt da sich der quick change
vorbereitet
da muss alles genau liegen die wir immer
wieder höre ich schon hundertmal jeden
tag die schauspieler seine shows statt
nicht in einem jahr auf sein
persönliches leben lang vom dienst durch
schilder zu bauen
durch immer trauern verbessert da einer
sagt gander hatten da passt und das
entwickelt sich peter marvey ist magier
illusionist zauberlehrling sagten die
als er noch peter wollenmann hieß und im
zürcher oberland neben mir in der schule
saß
damals hätte ich nicht darauf gewettet
dass der zurückhaltende peter einmal
rund um den erdball vor großem publikum
steht
wie ist aus meinem schüchternen
mitschüler ein magier von weltformat
geworden
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wir sind in malaysia
hier tritt peter moore ein halbes jahr
lang auf und trifft auf ein dankbares
publikum aus südostasien indien dem
nahen osten und china wechsel packen und
mit nach indien
mein gesehen konfus gelöst werden
[Musik]
genthin highlands ist ein kasino und
vergnügungs resort in der nähe der
hauptstadt kuala lumpur eine art las
vegas südostasiens
themenparks casinos spielhallen und
10.000 hotelzimmer locken besucher an
es ist der einzige ort in malaysia an
dem glücksspiel erlaubt ist
sechs abende pro woche steht peter
marvey in genthin auf der bühne
rund 80.000 zuschauer haben ihn bisher
gesehen
heute spielt peter seine hundertste
vorstellung die selbstdarstellung ist
teils eines magier geschäfts
dazu gehören viel glitzer und glimmer
und ein repertoire an theatralische
posen aus chemnitz ist das machbar sein
was uns in den gut fühlt und bei
depressiven und mit der jahre ist dass
es so gespielt dass ich kann also eine
spezielle kurse und das ist ihr recht
die haben mich bei dieser einigen
[Gelächter]
während der vorstellung muss dann jedes
detail reibungslos funktionieren
über 90 minuten hinweg wird ein minutiös
geplante ablauf haus gespielt mit viel
technik im hintergrund
[Musik]
bei der jubiläumsvorstellung in gelting
sitzt ein spezieller gast dem publikum
der schweizer botschafter in malaysia
einen schweizer künstler der über monate
hinweg in malaysia auftritt sieht auch
rolf lenz kaum jemals
[Applaus]
der botschafter kann sich aber erklären
warum gerade peter marwitz zauberei in
dieser welt gegen sehr gut ankommt dass
man die illusion sauber das mystische
natürlich noch geschätzt als als in der
schweiz
sie schätze er die show musik sehr
farbenprächtig also das ist es war
sicher sehr sehr zerrt ihn hinaus nd2o3
reise kennengelernt habe ich peter vor
28 jahren hier an der kantonsschule
zürcher oberland in wetzikon fünf jahre
gingen wir zusammen zur schule bis zur
natur
wenn ich daran zurückdenke kommt mir
stets dieses bildet sind in jeder
schulstunde übte peter kartentricks
unter der schulbank
ich hatte nicht den eindruck dass in die
schule groß beschäftigte die zauberei
hätten halten meisten interessierte mit
herz links und kurt einfach lösen und
somit da ich sie drauf gegangen mit
probepackung reise harley treffen wo es
ähnlich machen und ich habe mich da
passt es da das nicht logisch und so kam
ich bin zurzeit keinen grund dagegen
manchmal hatten wir ein wenig gelächelt
über das skurrile hobby unseres
klassenkameraden
und als er seine ersten vorführungen in
der aula der kantonsschule zeigte
zeichnete sich noch nicht unbedingt eine
weltweite karriere ab der große
entertainer war peter nicht von natur
aus bin ich nervös und gehemmt war
überhaupt der fall ist und da darf
erinnere mich wie es nachher eigentlich
fährt peter war wohl der einzige
teenager an der schule bin an den
mädchen in erster linie interessiert wie
man sie schweben lässt die fusion
überhaupt zeigen wirkt durchdacht
aber wo die kohle als auch wenn es keine
rockband
ich habe eigentlich nicht gewählt und
gemacht dass es auch ohne mich
fasziniert ich bin zwar schon einig sie
wollen uhr
jetzt muss mal nur überhaupt unterhalt
37 mm im hintergrund die fäden zogen in
lausanne ist sexy wie nachgang für zwei
tage und habe die natur bestand peter
danach verloren wir uns etwas aus den
augen
doch immer wieder hörte man peter habe
jetzt auftritte da und dort in der welt
und japan in china und dann er habe sich
ein haus in feusisberg gebaut mit
eigenem theater im erdgeschoss
spätestens jetzt lächelt wir nicht mehr
hier wohnt und arbeitet peter wenn er
nicht auf der bühne steht
an seiner seite ist die puerto ricanerin
viviana vega seine chef tänzerin
künstlerische leiterin und
lebenspartnerin schlecht scheint es ihm
seit der schule nicht ergangen zu sein
das gerät somit wurden eigentlich mit
zerbricht er schaffe drei moment wenig
aber bereits siebenten empfehlen
zauberer zwei turnieren wird von tihinen
das haben wir machen absolut das ist auf
jeden fall ja das kann ich überhaupt
nicht beklagen aber 200 prozentig
inzwischen mit dem anzeiger 4 100
prozentig jeden aspekt seines
unternehmens will peter unter kontrolle
haben bis hin zum design der kostüme das
leben dreht sich für das paar 24 stunden
um die zauberei gibt es momente die
nicht über die arbeit spricht ja wenn
wir schlafen das gute ist ja wir machen
alles zusammen wenn wir im restaurant
über etwas privates reden und einer hat
eine idee
dann können wir das gleich besprechen
und vielleicht entsteht daraus ein
tolles konzept
es ist super seine mitarbeiter immer
dabei zu haben und den boss der mir
erlaubt ihn umzusetzen
[Musik]
service business ist ein weltweites vor
malaysia hat es ihn schon in mehr als 30
länder gebracht
von auftritten in der schweiz allein
könnte er nicht leben aber man braucht
auch die freiheit des reisens dass die
zauberei mit sich bringt
die schweiz unterwegs bis er ihn immer
so und zwar schon recht langen dass ich
erst mal richtig märkte nicht noch zwei
saubere noack von hand architektur
studieren an der eth wahrscheinlich
nämlich gang jedoch im ausland arbeiten
heißt nicht ein ferien liegen führen
[Musik]
täglich werden peter und wie sie von
ihrer wohnung in kuala lumpur nach gent
in highlands gefahren peter nutzt die
zeit für büroarbeit bei der hundertsten
fahrt ist die aufsicht nicht mehr so
interessant
[Musik]
20 kilometer hinter kuala lumpur breitet
sich der dschungel in die berg aus das
kühle klima macht die gegend als
erholungsgebiet für städte attraktiv
1971 wurde auf 1800 metern höhe genthin
highlights eröffnet mitten im urwald 20
millionen besucher jährlich zieht das
resort gemäss offiziellen zahlen an
doch im westen ist der ort weitgehend
unbekannt das publikum kommt aus
malaysia und den umliegenden ländern
las vegas stand hier wohl park das
richtige las vegas hingegen hat für
marvin großen glanz verloren unter
anderem wegen dumpinglöhnen
[Musik]
schlimm
die sprecher aller für schlecht
vermeiden können
das nicht so spannend erzählen bio heißt
das es muss kommen
aber es gab sehr schönes war heute in
deutschland wären interessant wie er in
las vegas berichtet das japanische land
viel auf sich sein
[Musik]
an las vegas erinnert hingegen morris
optischer stil den andere magier ganz
ähnlich zur schau tragen wenn du das ich
denke er sollte mir da kann jeder machen
hatte ich mich entscheide wenig legt das
versucht dann jede mögliche etwas anders
10 10 ist auch wann das zeigen die
andere generell die hev concealer das
eigene das selbstgemachte ist peter
wichtig und das betrifft jeden
bestandteil seiner show
[Musik]
seine illusionen und bühnenelemente sind
unikate more wie entwickelt als eine
maschinerie in selber
[Musik]
zu hause in feusisberg entwirft und
konstruiert er die technischen
komponenten mit einem team von
assistenten ein zauberer ist für mary
auch ein handwerker ingenieure und
erfinder
ich fange er es überlegt gehirn bis wann
wenig verrückt und das oft realität
bringen und am schlussverkauf ich dachte
ja nur sondern ich trete mit dem lied
wenn das c und nur einmal auf der welt
und als entwickler das ist für mich
genauso wie ich diese strecke
das gehört einfach zu locken das wissen
über mechanik und elektronik hat sich
peter selbst angeeignet und mit jedem
fehler in jeder neuen konstruktion kommt
wieder etwas dazu
kritiker haben
auf der bügel seines hauseigenen
theaters kann der daniel düsentrieb auch
gleich alles testen
das ist normal es gibt aus oder ein
handwerk macht um uns nach vorn zu wenig
erfahrung erhalt das virus dringt so
oder so an geschmack und da bin ich auch
nicht so aufgewacht
[Musik]
peters elternhaus steht in rüti im
zürcher oberland einen guten teil seiner
jugendzeit verbringt peter im bastelraum
seines vaters
[Musik]
das ist leider sich nur gerächt
die ersten konstruktionen hinterlassen
damals ihre spuren in der akkuraten
ordnung er hat wie viel wild ausgesehen
das ist alles funktionieren der aktive
marine garage über account zitronige
erfahrung
doch seine eltern sie nicht nur die
unordnung sondern auch wie peters magier
karriere nach der matur fahrt aufnimmt
er wird schweizer meister
dem kann weltmeisterschaften teil
gewinnt internationale wettbewerbe am
anfang muss seine schwester als
versuchskaninchen herhalten
heute spannt peter auch seine eltern ins
unternehmen ein
ja weil er frisches beruf gehören wieder
zum team und noch vorbereitungsarbeiten
woche für technik und tänzerinnen und
gerührt ja und ganz sind die letzte war
mit eigenen will man nicht abschalten
[Gelächter]
sony-chef jetzt wo ich die funktion
ich nehme würde er behaupte ich bin nach
realisieren wieder weg das ist einmal
gott also die geheime nicht denkt dass
die monster bühne stehst du bist ja
lange wenn man gerne spazieren und kann
diese dann in den modern oder
hallo wenn peter heute für einen
auslandseinsatz seine sieben sachen
packt ist das eine logistische
generalstabs aktion die ganze ausrüstung
muss in einen sattelschlepper verladen
werden
für den navi extra eine zufahrt in sein
haus gebaut hat sieben tonnen material
in 61 kisten müssen verfrachtet werden
[Musik]
in der welt und inzwischen ist es kann
kaum verbessern ein g 212 hilft damit
aber nur geistig aber das kann nur die
größere hilfe
glaubt man den aufschriften ist hier
aber kein zauberkünstler unterwegs
sondern ein kinderzirkus es gibt
situationen wo ich eine flasche wasser
brauchen und schlitzt york was die
nachfrage an und wenn sich interessant
da raushält
und dann schnappt oder lastwagen und
damit dass weniger passiert will man
kinderzirkus und sie ist einfach nicht
interessant
auch auf diese idee muss man erst kommen
[Musik]
marvells engagement in malaysia ist sein
bisher letztes an einem stück aber bei
sechs monaten am selben ort ist auch bei
ihm eine grenze erreicht seither
getränkt und
das wiederholt sich
und dann wo auf der welt ich pk das
nächste mal antreffen könnte weiß er
noch nicht
[Musik]
aber wenn er weiter zieht muss ihm seine
entourage folgen
im ausland wird das team zu kleinen
familie welche auch die zeit nach den
shows teilt besonders für peter und
willi bedeuten die monate in malaysia
auch sie leben und arbeiten 24 stunden
täglich zusammen
sie teilen quasi tisch bett und bühne
ich glaube wir haben eine gute balance
zwischen bühnen und privatleben
das ist super ich mag das ich kann heute
in kuala lumpur sehen was peter schon
vor 25 jahren in der schule ausgemacht
hat
er lässt sich nicht beirren und er setzt
alles auf eine karte
für ihn steckt offenbar in der zauberei
die ganze magie des lebens
[Musik]